I started out as a stand-up who did
political material and it had been I
done a couple of one-woman shows that
had been based on sort of the evolution
of 24-hour news and media and during the
first Gulf War it occurred to me that
CNN had been spending more and more
money on graphics and less and less
money on research and it was like well
that's kind of a sounding alarm that I
think through comedy I kind of want to
do through my stand-up to talk about
that and then it became that there was
things like there was always children
disappearing on the news and like we
never got the big story and so I'd been
talking about these in my one-woman
shows in my stand up and then Comedy
Central New my stand-up and I'd done
specials for them and stuff and so then
they said would you want to come and
create a show that responds to the world
on a daily basis and I said yeah but I
said I one of my big sticking points is
that it's not just the politicians and
the newsmakers it's the media itself
that's as big of a player in the
landscape so if you want to do it where
we actually become a media outlet and
become them and show how sort of Remus
they are in reporting the facts and
getting it wrong as well as taking on
the powerful I'm all for it and they
said that's a great idea and so
Madeleine Smith morgue and i created
this machine that is now the Daily Show
well I think that there was several
different as we were developing the show
there was all sorts of different camps
as we were on the air about people that
wanted to focus on pop culture and
people who wanted to focus on politics
and what was going to be engaging and I
was sort of fighting for politics and
the people were fighting for pop culture
so we had this meld of politics and pop
culture and when John came on board John
was really let's take on the people that
are the big giant offenders and
hypocrites which are corporate
corporations and the media and
politicians so that when the show really
started going for sort of really healthy
big targets of big bullies that's really
when it started to shine and John is
somebody who really knows that game and
through humor you know he always says
the show is funny first and then you
know the points come through second and
so but he really knows and understands
that picking on the big targets and
pointing out their hypocrisy is
definitely the best way to go when it
comes to a political satire
well I think there's the political
climate I mean when it was being
developed and it was the last years of
Clinton you know remember that Clinton
wasn't always just Monica you know there
was welfare reform there was all sorts
of stuff that happened those elections
were also really great so the show built
itself on that and then when the bush
administration took off yeah i mean it's
it's sort of incredible how it felt like
we hired them so we can everett aerial
like there really wasn't an election we
just paid off America to vote for george
bush so that we could have a show
well I think you're forgetting a whole
part of the political landscape which
was the Bush administration you had ten
Republican candidates only three of them
believe in evolution you had Mitt Romney
you had Mike Huckabee you had Hillary
you had Bill Clinton running off the
rails you had this power struggle
between the first viable female
candidate for president and the first
viable african-american candidate and
then you had John McCain on his own
being a complete he was like Yosemite
Sam then Sarah Palin happened so there
was a wealth of material and also don't
forget we had wiretapping we had crazy
you know attorneys who were you know
political appointees from pat robertson
university we had Katrina you know there
was so much going on before the election
into the election the candidates
themselves and John Edwards don't forget
that you know Palin didn't come till
September of 2007 and so 2008 I'm sorry
so there was that was I mean I have to
say I don't Tina Fey was probably
sitting in her underwear eating cheerios
on that morning when they stood on the
stage in Minnesota and I'm sure she spit
whatever was out in her mouth and said
oh my god the dumbest woman in the world
looks just like me catching
I just finished doing a one-woman show
about Obama's first hundred days and
it's not hard at all because Obama cook
you know Obama is hope and change and
he's historic but he's a politician he
came up from the machine you know he's
not Gandhi he is a centrist he is
inconsistent you know I think for me
progressives lobbed on so much on to
Obama he never claimed he was a
progressive and so there's a lot of
humor mind in what people expected Obama
to be because they didn't ever read his
books or look at how he legislated and
he has had hysterical moments you know
he's not an idiot like bush so I think
you have to be smarter in your politics
which means your audience hopefully is
smarter and paying more attention but
you know you have a treasury our
economies falling apart and there's one
guy that works at the Treasury Tim
Geithner be and they can't find anyone
else to fill the jobs because oh all of
those people have committed crimes so
there's that there's Larry Summers you
know there's Obama expanding the
wiretapping program there's the closing
of Gitmo there's Dick Cheney unavoidable
for comment up you know espousing his
bizarro belief system you know there's
torture memos so there has been there
hasn't been a beat a moment that has
fallen off we're like what are we going
to talk about it is it is seamlessly
transitioned from Bush into Obama in
just a very different way of looking at
things
in general the media is always a source
it's sort of my raison d'etre you know I
absorb print media I absorbed TV media
at the moment the Morning Joe program I
am completely obsessed with because I i
watch Joe Scarborough bully Mika
Brzezinski and it feels like she has
Stockholm Syndrome it feels like
everyone on that show is so unhealthily
codependent on each other that it's like
watching one of those weird imps and
family dramas play out in front of you
except with some current events in it
I think that the people who have been
doing political satire or the people
i've talked to have really felt like it
used to be them again the media was the
watchdog for those you know the
government and corporate america and
when the media sort of felt like it was
in bed and they were lazy or in bed with
with their you know advertisers I think
comics naturally started filling the
role of sort of being the watchdog of
the watchdog you know political satire
and comedy we just started asking the
questions that journalists weren't
asking anymore through humor through
sort of hopefully funny righteous anger
but also just asking questions that our
audience wanted to hear and so we were
doing basically a service we just kept
doing we were doing but then it just
transitioned into like find out what's
going on or if we're just going to be
lied to from right left and center to
provide a haven where at least people
can come together and not feel crazy
feel like hey I'm in a group of people
who have understand that everybody
spinning us and somebody's onstage
pointing that out through humor at least
I can breathe a sigh that i'm not insane
when I hear the cacophony of lies
I think comedy can be a tool for social
activism I think that when you point out
hypocrisy again because the media often
doesn't you know the follow-up question
should just be put in the Smithsonian as
a relic of media because there are no
follow-ups anymore people don't have
enough historical knowledge to say wait
you're lying if you don't have enough
you know knowledge on the environment to
say wait scientists say there's global
warming it's real so a lot of
information just sort of floats out
there like like a thick muggy day and
nobody weeds through it and cuts through
the muck and says here's the truth and I
think that pointing that out through
humor can be a tool to have people say
wow I should be asking questions and I'm
laughing and I think that's what's fun
is that you can ask questions yourself
on stage through humor and then that
means the audience kind of scratches its
head and says you're right and as you
watch videos on the web and the daily
show colbert bill maher you will see
them lay out a case and make it funny
through video through things that are
out there somebody says one thing one
day and something else the next day and
you know we have this amazing medium
with which we can put it out there
you know rachel maddow ed schultz and
keith olbermann you know there's this
trifecta on MSNBC that is trying to get
to the bottom of the story and look
between the lines of the story and you
know I did a radio show with rachel
maddow for a year and together it was
sort of like I was the color commentator
and she was the person that was bringing
all of these stories that were buried in
independent media or that were not
covered at all and we would get experts
and she would drill at home and then I
would sort of provide the humor and
outrage of the listener I was learning
it for the first time along with Rachel
and it was really helpful I mean I guess
and I hope that they continue to do that
my fear is that if new shows you know
keep reading the chatter about how most
people get kids get their news from The
Daily Show which I don't believe is true
I think young people get their news and
then they go to the Daily Show for
response because you wouldn't like The
Daily Show if you didn't know it was
going out of the news so it's kind of a
false premise but I hope they don't
start feeling like because the Daily
Show is a successful place for people to
go and sort of have a catharsis that
they become that I hope they still
become interesting compelling and and
using humor certainly voices of reason
and not comedians
i would say jon stewart probably does
have more influence aid because you can
count on one hand the number of actual
broadcast journalists are on television
let's not let's not call them broadcast
journalists when eighty percent of them
are commentators you know how many
broadcast journalists are on Fox how
many broadcast journalists who went to
journalism school were investigative
reporters worked at newspapers have
Pulitzer zor Peabody's for digging into
a story and making it great there is
very very few so if you're going to have
a landscape of people commentating jon
stewart actually calls the materials and
looks at things and presents it in a
funny way but nonetheless there's truth
there he's not making up news to make a
joke he's taking the reality of the news
and and spinning the hypocrisy in it and
using here we're doing it so yeah that
person is going to definitely be more
influential I think then somebody who's
just some ex-congressman who's literally
wondering aloud on television bloviating
their opinions that are based on
newspaper things that you've read I've
read I mean that's what's crazy is that
they say things I learned nothing
because I already read that in fact you
watch new shows and they read you the
paper it's like really is this what
broadcast news has come to is they read
the paper and then tell you what's in
the paper and so if newspapers are
crumbling what will become a broadcast
news it's a very interesting dilemma
that I think they're going to find
themselves in
i like to call them the fright wing and
you know when you scare people and you
indulge their fears that's an easy
emotion to live with your validated in
your your fear of of race your fear of
of terrorists your fear of anything it
almost is like what glenn beck does
which i think is the most frightening
thing is that he is basically telling
his viewers that they have no control
and that they should be afraid and that
is this really scary false premise
because if you're a human being and you
feel like everything is happening to you
you want someone to take care of you and
that was one thing I was fascinated with
the Bush administration was if you look
at the history of what George Bush told
America it was look I'm gonna take care
of everything well you can stay on the
couch and you can just be against
abortion and hate the gays and hate stem
cell research and before this war I'm
not going to ask you to fight and so you
can have a set of values that allows you
to still sit in your recliner and be
judgmental whereas it's it's actually
more interesting as you watch the
elevation of of lefty blogs and
progressive pundits they're asking you
to participate and when people start
participating what they find out is
their part of the community they want to
help other people they see that if they
actually get off the couch and start
reading and listening and taking a stand
and getting into the neighborhoods they
can actually accomplish something in a
neighborhood scale and they see how that
transforms incredibly and using the
internet as a tool has been just an
unbelievable boon for the proactive
well you know it sometimes I feel a
little bit with YouTube it's like you
know when you go to a discount store
like Marshalls or TJ maxx and you know
that there's one prata suit in all of
those racks of crap um it's how how
dedicated are you to weeding through the
bowl to actually find the one or two
amazing items that are there and I think
that while YouTube has become a
certainly a place where you can find
amazing pieces of satire in comedy I
think that really good stuff gets lost
there because you you'll see that there
are places like barely political and
Huffington Post where if you know
there's a destination on the web now for
satire you'll go there rather than
trying to scour through you i mean if i
were to Google you know political satire
I mean like YouTube a search of
satirical videos I mean you holy moly
you know it's providing a place for a
lot of people to put them up it's not
really helping weed out which ones are
sort of making a point which ones are
just funny and stuff like that it gives
people an outlet to do stuff which I
like I think the one thing that I find
incredibly awesome about the Internet is
is that it kind of weeds out the
complainers because now you have a tool
and a device with which you can learn to
shoot and learn to edit and write
material and start your own web page and
put your stuff up and send it out to the
world and and if you want to really dig
around you can find websites who you can
contact and say hey I'm doing these
videos that I think would be right for
your site so it's it's really getting
the activists who are thinking about
getting their message out it gives them
an opportunity because for years we as
filmmakers and writers and producers and
actors had to wait for some network or
some casting director to give us a forum
and now we don't have to
do that anymore so people are still
complaining then they're not really
utilizing all that's available to them
are you Christopher Hitchens um of
course not of course men aren't funnier
than women I I don't even understand
really funny here's the deal about funny
I just had a huge fight on my Facebook
page with a guy who said you're not
funny lizz winstead and I was like well
you're not funny either and then I
realized that I went to his little face
book page and I thought he was a comic
that goes on the road and funny
subjective funny is like you know sushi
do you like sushi or do you not like
sushi and then what kinds of sushi do
you like if someone's making a living
doing comedy then people think they're
funny I might not find them funny but
others do so for anyone to make any
broad statement about what's funny what
isn't funny people who say there's lines
that you can cross in comedy are people
who are destroying the creative process
there's never a line in comedy you never
know what a line is because someone may
cross it consistently for the way one
person looks at humor and that same
routine may never cross the line so I
just boundaries and what's funny I just
feel like it's all so subjective that I
always say if you don't think I'm funny
please tell your like-minded friends
that I'm not funny because then I don't
have to worry about them coming to my
show feeling like they wasted their
money and they hated it you know and if
you do think I'm funny then please tell
people because then everyone can have a
good time
well I think for christopher hitchens
it's that he it just feels so weirdly I
mean it's weird i did a panel with him
the summer and he couldn't have been
more cordial to me at after he'd written
that thing and they were going to bring
it up and talk about it they never did
and I was more than willing to do that I
think it's it comes from an ignorance
that if you aren't open to allowing
someone to make you laugh if you've
never seen a woman make be funny then
you're just a sexist asshole like it's
crazy if one woman has made you laugh
ever in the history of your life that
means women are fine like and so I don't
know where it comes from it comes
through it d if you say that then you
ain't when I I think that you then you
are not open to hearing what women have
to say and you're probably not funny and
you're probably threatened by women who
can command attention in a room work it
make people laugh because you can't I
mean that's all that's the only
explanation I can think of is that you
just hate women
no I think there's bad dirty jokes and
there's good dirty jokes and if you
execute a dirty joke poorly it's
cringe-worthy if it's funny it's funny I
think that Sarah Silverman and you know
various other women want a psych so i
think is great Roseanne who has amazing
some really good like you know blue
material I do some dirty jokes and I've
never had a problem those women don't
have problems it's all in the execution